I would break up right now do you all
live together we do yeah I would say hey
I'm GNA go ahead and move out this
weekend and I love you I'll probably
always love you and it's been so
great wow is that not what you thought I
was gonna
say no I honestly I was hoping you'd say
more but I honestly expected it here's
here's why I'm saying that number one I
dated my wife for 5 years off and on we
broke up a whole bunch we're in college
out of all that so the the time doesn't
bother me um some coupes datay for six
years seven years some couples datay for
three months right um that's that's just
life but for whatever reason and you've
heard me say this on the show a million
times behavior is a language and for
whatever reason he is telling you I've
got other priorities that are not you
right now